on a plein de réunions parisiennes alors
notammentcito les loissures et voilà il
y à chaque fois la France quel que soit
le gouvernement on est ils sont
tranquille il CR toujours plus fort il
arrive à un moment où nous agriculteurs
on veut bien avme plus contraignante on
comprend que le consommateur n'est pas
envie d'avoir des produits
phytosanitaires dans son assiette mais
il nempêche que nous on nous interdit
plein de solutions françaises et par
contre bah les voisins il les utilisent
largement et on importe ses produits
chez nous c'est ça qui nous gêne voilà
c'est ça c'est uniquement ça qu'on on
respecte la la R ation européenne point
barre mais qu'on mette pas plus alors ça
c'est la première mesure la deuxième les
jà cher j'adore Christophe il a fait
cher ça c'est ça c'est régist on se
partagejà cher les zones improductives
c'est-à-dire B du jour au lendemain on
vous dit supprimer 4% de vos terres de
production pourquoi comme ça voilà une
décision de l'Europe c'est comme ça ça
tombe ce matin on était on était sur un
barrage avec il y avait un jeune
agriculteur qui vient de s'installer il
a repris 60 hectares
60 heares il devra laisser 4 % cette
année de
zone de Ja cher improductive
improductive donc c'est inadmissible
c'est 4 % du revenu qui saute tout de
suite ces chosesl il faut qu'il nous
l'annonce très vite c'est pas déj cher
voilà ces TER là servent à produire de
la des céréales du sucre pour les
éleveurs c'est nourrir les animaux c'est
c'est tout ça et ça c'est inadmissible
mais cette elle existe aussi bien en
Italie en Espagne a que en France là là
ça je crois que c'est partout en Europe
mais vous savez les autres pays il
sortent aussi vous avez vu ce qui se
passe au niveau européen ça ça c'est un
peu ça c'est partout ça ça c'est partout
mais mais bon eux ils ont déjà comme ils
ont dit tout à l'heure nous on a déjà
d'énorm plus il ça il faudrait même au
niveau européen parce que tout les pays
européens et tous les agriculteurs
d'Europe aimeraiit que ça on on a on
annule cette mesure qui est qui est qui
qui peut pas qui peut qui qui pour eux
les étr totalement donc si on arrive à
enlever ces deux mesures làà
il y a pas que celle-là il y en a
d'autres c'est bon
sens on parle de de deux voilà après il
y a plein d'autres dossiers mais voilà
c'est les deux
effectivement VO c'est ça donc ça ce
serait alors juste Christophe avant
avant que que je vous libère juste parce
que je vous dis tout ce qu'on voit on me
dit voilà on m'envoie votre profil
Christophe Grison on dit que vous êtes
président d'une grosse COP dans l'Oise
et alors alors je je sais pas c'est quoi
une grosse coopérative faut savoir qu'
en France on livre nos céréales à un
organisme stocker l'organisme ur il y a
deux choix soit des privés soit des
coopératives les coopératives
appartiennent leurs agriculteurs on a un
capital social et je suis entre
guillemets le garant financier que le
retour financier quand la coopérative
gagne de l'argent ben ça retourne aux
agriculteurs par exemple on a envoyé 13
millions d'euros l'été dernier à nos
agriculteurs à 1400 agricul a pas de mal
en fait non je suis juste le garant que
l'argent retourne à m agricul avez le
droit quand même de défendre agcur vous
avez droit c'est parce que tu as reçu un
texto qui te dit jeis président de
coopérative oui Val France coopérative
qui en plus tout sonblé on collecte
800000 tonnes autour de Paris ça va de
pont saintte maence à Fontainebleau et
ça va à destination de tous les gens ici
parce qu'on on est fournisseur assez
large de la meunerie parisienne voilà
alors juste il paraît que il y a
quelqu'un qui me disait on vous payez
payer la viande 4 € p on leur paye la
viande 4 € le kilo et nous on la vend 30
€ le kil derrière enfin il la vend 30 €
le kilo derrière la comment c'est c'est
c'est c'est qu' des gens quand même qui
se gaffent sur vos sur vos côtes c'est
c'est c'est c'est les négociations
justement on appelle ça la loi égalime
nous ce qu'on demande aujourd'hui c'est
la partage de la marche on demande pas
on demande pas que le produit augmente
au consommateur aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué pour se nourrir ou en on est
tous pareil ce qu'on demande c'est
un/ers un/ers 1 tiers c'est pas dur
c'est enfin voilà c'est trop longtemps
le bon sens bon non mais tout ce que
vous dites et je tiens à le dire ce que
disent les agriculteurs les agriculteurs
ils font chier personne ils ont jamais
fait chier personne ils travaillent ils
font leur truc et c'est grâce à eux
qu'on arrive à se nourrir ça fait des
années qu'il font chier personne et qui
sont étranglés de plus en plus et qui
qui disent rien et qui continuent à
Leser travailler tout tout on on s'est
plongé dedans tout ce qui demande
franchement c'est que du bon sens il y a
que c'est c'est pas il y a rien de fou
il y a pas parfois il y a eu des gens
qui ont fait des revendications ici on
se disait bon ils rêvent ils sont
complètement fous moi je ve vous dire à
un moment on a eu des gens aussi voilà
je me rappelle un moment sur les les les
les les les chauffeurs à ATP et cetera
voilà qui qui font un travail qui font
un gros travail mais voilà qui qui qui
ont quand même des salaires qui sont qui
sont quand même voilà qui sont qui sont
bien au-udessus de ce que tout
agriculteurs exactement les agriculteurs
aujourd'hui tout ce qu' demande c'est du
bon sens et c'est pas de la folie c'est
pas des mecs qui sont fous qui sont
réveillés un matin qui sont dit nous on
veut
gagner 10000 € par mois et moins
travailler et avoir des normes qui sont
complètement impossible à à tenir donc
voilà donc les mecs c'est pas des fous
c'est juste des gars qui qui prennent
aujourd'hui 800 € par mois alors qu'il
travaillent comme des chiens et qui
aujourd'hui peuvent pas vivre moi j'ai
j'ai parlé avec des agriculteurs ce
weekend ils m'ont dit ça fait des années
qu'on a pas été au restaurant hein
impossible d'aller au restaurant tu vois
donc et on a vu j'ai vu des enfants
d'agriculteur le pire c'est que la
plupart des enfants d'agriculteur aiment
tellement le métier ils ont tellement
l'amour du métier qu'ils veulent faire
agriculteur euxmême même si c'est
difficile même s'ils voient que leur
père ne s'en sort pas même s'il voi que
ils ont pas de loisirs comme comme les
autres enfants parce que c'est compliqué
et ben ils veulent quand même être
agriculteur ils disent bah c'est ma
passion et quoi qu'il arrive je je veux
être agriculteur je voyais des gens qui
étaient sur les barrages ce weekend qui
me disaient bah à 21h30 après on va
aller nourrir les bêtes parce que voilà
on va aller qu'on va quand même aller
bosser même le soir et c'est vraiment ce
sont des passionnés et je vous jure que
ce sont vraiment des gens qui qui n'ont
jamais profité du système ça a toujours
été le système qui a profité des
agriculteurs et à un moment il faut que
le système il arrête de profiter d'eux
et comme je le dis hein il y a tellement
de gens qui profitent du système et qui
sont tranquilles chezx je parlais des
agriculteurs je dis ce weekend encore je
leur disais est-ce que vous rendez
compte qu'il y a des gens qui foutent
rien et qui gagnent plus d'argent que
vous
et ouais et donc ça tu peux pas tu peux
pas entendre ça tu peux pas entendre ça
quand tu te réveilles le matin quand tu
travailles toute la journée tu peux pas
entendre qu'il y a des mecs qui
connaissent bien le système et qui font
des des des des magouilles enfin c'est
même pas des magouilles parce que ils
sont dans ils sont dans la lois ils sont
chez eux et et ils prennent des 2 2500
3000 € par mois à rien et je peut
dire qu'ils vont au restaurant ils vont
au cinéma ils kiffent leur journée hein
c'est pas comme les agriculteurs voilà
et ça c'est inadmissible ça c'est la
France qu'on ne veut pas la France qu'on
ne veut plus voilà on ne veut plus de ça
les assister on n veut plus voilà je
vous le dis ceux qui sont capables
d'aller travailler il faut qu'ils
aillent travailler et je préfère donner
l'argent à des agriculteurs je vous dis
qu'il se lèv le matin et les aider après
vous après je veux dire on va dire ouais
c'est utopiste non pas du tout moi je va
vous dire moi je préfère prendre
l'argent qu'on donne à des gens qui
profitent du système pour les donner à
nos amis agriculteurs qui se réveillent
le matin et leur et leur débloquer des
des choses qu'on fait fait chier
toujours les mêmes eu ils les font chier
avec des normes avec des trucs voilà
donc oui vous savez on veut on veut rien
nous on veut pas qu'on nous donne des
choses on veut simplement vendre nos
produits alors voilà c'est et du bon
sens dans notre métier ça va enlever le
mal-être qui a dans beaucoup
d'exploitation je vais vous donner un
exemple ce matin on avait un ami Pascal
qui est de loise qui raconte un petit
peu un contrôle qu'il a eu là il y a
quelques mois cet hiver vous avez vu
enfin depuis le mois d'octobre il
pleuvait beaucoup des fois 50 mm d'eau
les parcelles trempées il faut nettoyer
un moment ou un autre les animaux il
nettoyer ses animaux il ballait le
fumier donc dans sa parcelle il a eu un
contrôle il a été quasi verbalisé parce
qu'il avait pas aligné ses remorques
comme il fallait voilà où on en est
voilà on en est tu as raison ça c'est
des exemples et tout ça on va faire
remonter ces exemples là parce que c'est
une alors c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça
aujourd'hui les gens en on marre on Mar
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
alors je dit vous venez quand vous
voulez régissz Christophe bah déjà on
doit visiter la maison de
exactou rien avec plaisir tu sais quoi
ave des amours et et ne changez rien et
on a on a tellement envie que ça
s'arrange pour vous je vous
jure vous le méritez tellement on bloque
que les autoroutes on est vraiment
désolé on veut pas bloquer les routes on
veut pas bloquer les Parisiens qui vont
au boulot on sait que c'est compliqué
mais c'est un peu comme la personne
d'avant si on n pas une revendication je
dire je vous dis ça fait des années
qu'on dit que vous êtes dans dans la
merde et ça fait des années que ça bouge
pas à un moment là il faut vraiment que
tout le pays se mobilise je vous le dis
et que tout le pays derrière nos
agriculteurs parce que si ça bouge pour
eux ça bougera aussi pour nous surtout
pas de casse casse dans le respect des
biens et des personnes on a nos
gendarmes qui nous accompagnent les
forces de l'ordre nous ce qu'on veut
c'est voilà on ne marche plus sur la
tête les panneaux on les remet à
l'endroit et on roule j'ai vu un un
policier ce weekend qui était un génial
je lu dit alors vous soutenez les
agriculteurs dit bon je dis rien mais
parce qu'on a pas le droit de le dire
mais on les aime bien quand même voyez
ou pas merci en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous merci beaucoup
merci euh les
Chéries on va
passer on va passer au point people et
on va parler justement de la maison de
Johnny alors voilà j'espère que vous
allez pouvoir la voir celle-ci après les
aides du gouvernement euh voilà dans le
point P